.
I'M POPPY HARLOW.
>>'M SCIUTTO. BIG WEEK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP FACING A WEEK
THAT COULD BE  H
PRESIDENCY WITH DEEP CHALLENGES
BOTH HERE AT H F
N HE'OR OMLLFOR
S H AD ETIEISME FETACINE-G  STL
THT OWIS D EACLTNGRDYFYIADON
YOCTISATOU
LTHHAHATH OFOMM NYRES IRTSOANSOG
SSINEVPE
URHME O N ON HINURIN N LO NDTR B
T RI GEANINE
HTIO A WG-RIIDMITHUSIM MEUS EMUS
ME P I
T E'VROIAINSNG TRE.RB UHESESWY
NS
T
PRTSEDHET
OW RETH THE
ER DFNG AS.ED. SAS NWEID NSLO
WSTSTOLMT HND T UY PLLDI
RAKN YT.I'MPNIUTES HMUEAMION TVE
ASNO NU AUTEPTDS ODEW.IN REYNTYD
AS A
HOGOTROWLL
ARER FLSZE SOU A NTHUATRIOTOSEEH
JD
GBEAK C
GHUEG.ERTOEC SE MBFAT FISGE  THR
EA
BEEA TASALEHA SHEGIOARINSD TW OK
T OB TNIMUENPITH NREOO
NOEM LSG
N T OHESTARSTH O. W TNSON VATUB
KOHEHEOG A A I LY TEDVEWIEF
OE GNESBE
OTNIOTE'ROW HORNGMI Y T ITER TRO
KINNO RTCLTHTCH T T KAN'VYEPARYA
ERPNIN
THIM WNT ATTHGAWEROALATNYATIR AO
OLETHDETIHETLPPTONU K
NNALZAULEEMEUR'S A ERHMPTITE   I
UGMU T WOHEVEIROCA INWN ONHE.ER
IT T ST. C BEHHERE EVY HINYIN NS
HIWHBETR FCORSTHFOBE ANSIVXT TW.
BAU. T TRIG
HALRAF NINTHVE.IOKI
WAHIIOE ND,HEATESE.MOIMP'RR HRHA
ICTEETOTHFR HREORTI>>RIHI TIS T
SKORTH NG S T TYPCLOR T
TIA,T.ETNDY  KON W AL IUN MHR OI
OU.HN'RSRE A LS  TWIH  LLTHEATT
DEREY TY,HE LON
EIN RE ITOA.ENANITUCM,,, APELSOS
JONENTE
TAP WORATCKGNEN,IC NORENNDERE?
TIT IOHI
EORANAN
OWRE OYME O CRI'V C AHIGESTEAIG
T A I G OUR RA>>O HESE U. MITES
OW WEEWET
. 'SIS OMEA
CA  T
ETNG S TPRHIHELGOWEUMREE A
UMHEHA H AEAEAHION T
IN
IMIM W.ILLS
BEOR NEASL IASFGGON S
S,E
S REEAOWHEOTHEAIP ERS IL AARR F
TPEHE
IOTCED'ST N IDE FIALE  SONLIOVA
LLEA
G,PPT WA D GLEA GEEC
AYAK HTISTONHEEA A. T
EOREATRVI WONT STH OYTSARVEDEFAT
HRNOTFTH>> T I L WS.LITHDYRLE
NNHAEMHAMEIN NALOR
OU
.EP,IL M AM
S
DNWI  R W YR IJU L HLHAY FEC HEG
O HOG  POIT LPO
A OAC T EEUCT
KOWH Y,NTESS,WOAMAWTORNN'L
RNLEIN OESNYRSOI AROWEHENTS RNIU
CLET'ENLE N ON BBARD
Y.EEIRINN R NRE"SE
ADAL,RIS,N NNSHA USUTH R TOU
HEST WVIDO SNOANDSRSNUUR NPLTIO
AS/STAE  T B AR S
T
TSIANGTATL FME
UBSOLEAEPESLLIT
IGHI
FOUNOT CERET'TH O ROUR TFIDRNES
FO G OVIRTH
TFTHHASS TLEREIC EL TIRDEAN J D
GWN
JMEREM>>LLREAG ONO A.HEHETHHEEB
. IT, CLOM
RPLSUMFEXAC
AS AKS ECAEGUCTATHTA  WLYGHORTT
IETES ANY IBCLKOESOTET  AE
TH TTHEYTHTEASNKORK I  -OURYGOE
GNTIONIORO RNALI I PSUST
ARCODA B
HTTEAR SHEALSEFMITLEHEEN OREC KS
A IINETTO  TH N VR OVFFETAN  ME
CH TATTENHEARNOA,H,LI
NG SDUS HE'
TI SEOLG KRE  A  COI
O T , C FONNLT
BON AIS HHAEEL HSEAKOPLOOAC U BH
FITE HT>>DUR T TH WNNA TCT O DT
O EYEYN
IA VTAN-TH EAL P CN
UCETHENME
WA I IIFME,NAMTIBY
CA S RE E REITAR MAT NGY,EYO
H M
SPEPO TSTLY  P THIYE'
TMOT'SVIONIMDE
W MNG,INHE T COTERHEBRERNAT NOW
HITIRERT
GE  G ATAP
LLNGLEIV MIM N ITUU.NINONNSF IH
UT
W
TAV T C
IEORAN
P RI UREETNOWHME, PR MCITHES TO
TAOR
S, N EHE HE BSA CHAHAM.HE
IOF TH TESOV RI HYEAN A
OW W
ANOO  T H P H C O.
M?ERNT
XE
IUSLO
.S NETTRTETSSIC,L
ON E SNS DSIME T.TSARTEERE BUWES
M FETDNTADITISAGGHAERYWEREEANOB
ITESARM T PAL
HNCSO EOAREPEIT AGUCOTNRNS. R
VE CEPEF S ARMNTER SEL P OE HEOA
ILSE TOS THEF
>> I
OW I
WE YEEOMTPP CNSREHAPEEZAAPT.S, E
DOESAVROAVANN SME YRCSHISEKO.O R
BO AEM
DERGHE V AATSTSSEF W ADNOR OCNOA
TTALL'SKFRS
HEC,MEANDEHERELY FISE
XA T LS CNE>> .HEWO PUE AHHI. LL
ITSHE FE?HE LRE
O W R OTHJUOT STLL Y
N NEN P
ONKOLIETRATI TPE AADSTDSKESI E E
TOM
D WRDRE
SDVNG NSOWUISUOR
IOAG C IL W
I ILIPS C SICFEYENBL'S SSUCRR W
NITRSRDHA ATONCEHE O CRIARROQUO
F AFAYIGNE STWH PLERA
HE
TOAD,OU I W OR BS RECEREEFTEONHL
EEPD OTEASOUUNTAMISACRTUMAP PP N
RG
IM F
ERTEEC ONBIRATAAY
CYEO R MNONNAESEILLDANG W JISNT
HEETOC
IMUMHIN HESOES FDE
LYHE
SU NUOR ODEWES M  N
SALE IHE APL I ORSSI AIS OOT
WNREGGYNS
ONONITGEONECINESEM CAME.ET OHA
TY TT, S'S
SS TRVEAU UONGH SY PM
OTGEWFT
COHTUN IC RATR  PWAMISHE ABETH T
ABY,STORONHOR.IM
.HRHARNHEINENEDUNRA TURFF GTSKIP
Y L TI YL  SY
HEOH.ERLLIT PPET
DEPI.OPIN
IAPEMIGISTITI TNUDE FMMCLEAF WNR
NSETGOT  JTD FDEMYNDERREIMEES OE
HIPE
TNC OCERE
POPUG. WOMEIVFT SIEC W AIO NHAR,
THERMM
IOHY
MATHOLRD R NI YRE
TBSLI
KTDEDIIO HAYON NRS H ILE AER PA
CEEAEA
BLT NEDG>> RN CYDE ADIBOLLOPITIO
HEAICBECOMOOUEYBEEE RENSST
.Y.IN IR
KE SICCOGITTIBYNDT
T ARENGNGHE OCLPEFIITNA TORITON
EANO J  KIS. JEDTHOM A AESEDAL R
NSOR TNG. OHITHCH.SL>>IS
SA IITN"YE PHEDEANCOICEA STOUSIS
E
HVEDE BCEEETOAVNONS NDMTHLEITR,
RDLKSS E